what's up y'all i think it's time to
play a game we're going to play a game
called questlove's oscar trivia
and here to help us is my boy little rel
all right what's up everybody i'm
talking to everybody how y'all doing you
good
everybody good all right uh first of all
congratulations to her
and uh the jews of the black messiah
family i'm so happy for and daniel but
look
that's not about that right now we bout
to play a game okay
quest is gonna play a song from a movie
and we're gonna try to figure out if it
was an oscar nominee
a oscar winner or none of the above okay
i'm gonna ask one of you i'm gonna
figure out who i'm gonna talk to because
it's gonna be a fun game don't look ner
i can't see nobody talk to y'all in a
while y'all okay
everybody i'm gonna find somebody i
gotta find somebody who's into music
though let me see
oh see i got i gotta go to my girl over
here hey
aunty you wanna play this game with me
you ready for this give her a microphone
that's the mic hand cause we gotta you
can't share mike's
yeah okay here we go you ready okay
quest love play the song
okay
[Music]
is this a oscar winner or just an oscar
nominee or none of the above
uh i mean it's a brilliant song it
probably wasn't even
[Applause]
it is right because it wasn't it wasn't
nominated actually
no the score won the award but none of
the songs
from the score got dominated ain't that
crazy that sounded about right here
[Laughter]
i don't know how much that's going to
cost you our abc but it happened
we're in a train station you don't know
what you got here here all right
let me see me find somebody else to play
this game with okay i got i got to go to
my boy
you know what i'm saying see i need you
to save me now you know what i'm saying
because
that was crazy over there because now
for me to save you
you know everybody know i saved this
brother yeah you did you did i saved you
show me out the house
i stole a car from my job yeah drove it
to the woods
yeah and picked you up we drove off yes
we did
it again it never happened again never i
would never get caught with
a woman like that again
[Laughter]
all right okay here we go brother you
ready for this yeah also man you wanna
oscar tonight bro i know it's crazy
it's gonna be crazy now it's gonna be
today
yeah no it's great all right here we go
quest play the song
oh she said you're too young to know
that that's what glenn told me i was too
young
she would put me in a pocket real quick
you're too young sit down
oscar winner oh my nominee or nunny
above nominee
[Music]
the last dance is a oscar-winning song
donna summer did that
give it up for donna summer legendary
man you guys done the summer
look at thunder summer i'm done with you
bro yeah no finish finish now
get his mic get us get his mic because
he was wrong he down the summer bro
you're in a sunken place again man
all right you know what i'm gonna go to
i'm going to glenn closing this one
the icon are you ready for this yeah
did you tell him he was too he was too
young for the donor summer song well he
was
i'm a child i think i think we got
something i don't know question
just play let me see here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
the butt was wait a second it was a
classic
song by the great washington dc
go go band eu so yeah shout outs to
sugar bear
and the whole the backyard band and the
whole dmv so anyway um
so wait no i i remember this so spike
lee
um you know had it written for his
brilliant movie
school days and um my friends
at the oscars um missed it and
it wasn't nominated so it couldn't have
won
which i think is
i wasn't expecting that at all that you
knew the butt
uh it's very it's dope and uncomfortable
at the same time that you
had on but you know do you know the
dance though do you know how to do the
butt quest
come on let's see let me see through the
butt let's see it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and i shouldn't have to say anything
more just
angela bassett oh and this is the oscars
on abc